you can't win if you don't like it
because somebody else likes it and
they're going to outwork
you I dat trade attention and build
businesses Legacy is greater than
current I know it's your first New York
ComicCon in this capacity super exciting
for the company how you feeling right
off the path just complete chaos which
excites me to no end all the energy is
always going to excite I'm an energy
person and so the fact that so many
people are going to walk in and stumble
into be friends and be like what's be
friends what's be friends what's be
friends that excites me I think what
you're going to see from be friends over
the next 6 to 12 months is more
affirmation to the fact that this is a
brand that has the Ambitions to be at
the highest
[Music]
levels for Scissors Shoot oh eat it kid
I met you at a garage sale last month
free field if you remember I'm actually
here so I can buy another VRI no kidding
you garage sale yeah my man because of
you I was there to buy another V friend
I got a series one gift cat and a series
2 gift cat since then so I just want to
say thank you can't believe I met you
man relocating in a couple of weeks with
no job man I'm kind of like Shing right
now yeah definitely but uh any advice
don't be scared be patient like it's
okay to live in the dirt to find
happiness you're young you got time yeah
you know what I mean so like people jump
into too early cuz they're they're
stressed you got time that's the answer
appreciate that you nice to meet
you Dustin both clips of rock paper
scissors going to put together and then
I want the whole thing to be like nobody
on Tik Tok can beat me in rock paper
scissors let's BL that out that'll work
what do you see in the future for social
media you know what's funny the reason I
think I have a good track record and the
way you set that up is I don't like
predicting I move fast when there's new
stuff I taste it I watch it I analyze it
and then there's a moment where I think
it's crossed over intuitively and that's
when I get loud I look at all technology
that way and on the flight out here we
were working on a new book ironically
about where social media is right now
and I didn't realize I was on YouTube so
early YouTube came out on December 15th
2005 wine L TV was February 21st 2006 So
within 2 months of YouTube being out I
had a long form show and I think from
that day to this day I'm proud that I'm
still in the dirt in the trenches in the
streets and I think I'll stay that way
forever cuz that's the part that brings
me the most
[Applause]
Joy all right let's get into it you know
maybe I had it right with my first book
my first book subtitle of crush it was
cashing in on your passion maybe what
was clear to me in my early 30s has has
become again very clear to me as I get
closer to 50 I don't know how you can
work hard enough to beat your
competition if you don't like the thing
you're doing you can't win if you don't
like it because somebody else likes it
and they're going to outwork you it's
not sustainable unless you love the
process it's too hard to be an
entrepreneur I know it got cool I'm a
direct beneficiary of it becoming cool
but if I could wish anything for
everybody in this room as I look corner
to corner besides health I would wish
you self-awareness there's a lot of
people say sitting in here wanting or
are delusional that they're a great
entrepreneur and what they really are is
a great number two and a great number
three the number four at Facebook and
Tesla made a lot more money than 99.9%
of the number ones that started
companies everybody's so focused on what
they wish they could be that they're not
paying attention to who they are I
seriously I come out today a school
teacher that teaches entrepreneurship
and finance to a group of kids paid for
probably about 5050 high schoolers that
he teaches to come to this event it's
amazing but where's that group of high
[Applause]
schoolers what piece of advice if you
gave one piece of advice in high school
what what would you tell the the high
school there they literally are sitting
there thinking they they're getting
close to having to have their
figured out kids I got a big one for you
you know how your parents and teachers
are telling you like you got to get
focused you got to figure out
your you're not going to believe
this it's really funny none of
them have their figured
out all right that's good you guys give
Round of
Applause thank you San
Diego Thank
[Applause]
you the keynote koala this token allows
you to go to any keynote that I'm doing
publicly in the world you'll have
ridiculously good seating and a minimum
of a 10-minute Green Room session with
me before I take the stage jam with my
friend Michael Ruben and helping out on
this all-in challenge I'm giving away a
workout with me and Bean you're going to
be a guest of my podcast and I'm going
to fly you all paid plus one to three of
my Keynotes ladies and gentlemen welcome
to a special edition of the money
Mondays podcast on the money Mondays we
talk about three core topics how to make
money how to invest money and how to
give it away to charity there is no
better person to ask these type of
questions to than the one the only Mr
Gary ve my
guys I hate when people invest in
they don't understand cuz someone smart
told them you know what I will say for
sure and this is what my number one
belief is is that it's the cross-section
of something you like and something you
[Music]
understand I'm pretty much stuck in
between I'm working for a company and
painting so are you trying to do the art
full time competition just gets me
nervous what the do they have
competition is fake there's nobody
beating you there's nobody taking your
paper that's just your insecurity be
friends this thing I'm trying to build
this whole Comic-Con is competition and
they're all further ahead than I am none
of them are stopping me from building
[Music]
beend
yeah